me better than
UK new year new Miley Miley Cyrus has
dropped her highly anticipated single
flowers and fans are speculating that
the song is about her ex-husband Liam
Hemsworth and we're breaking down all
the theories why we think so too so the
new track is offered highly anticipated
new album Endless Summer vacation
however Miley dropped flowers today on
January 13th which just so happens to be
Liam Hemsworth's birthday
Miley adds even more fuel to the fire by
lyrically referencing a house fire which
seems to nod at her and Liam's Malibu
home burning down in 2018 in a wildfire
[Music]
now in a promo video for the release of
flowers Miley can be seen doing a unique
dance on the street
to which fans noted she previously did
this same type of dance on a red carpet
interview with Liam to which he asked
her to not do the dance but the most
prominent Easter egg that flowers is
about Miley's relationship with Liam is
how the song seems to be a response to
Bruno Mars's When I Was Your Man a song
that is about regrets after a
relationship and is a song that fans
believe that Liam had previously
dedicated to Miley take a listen
[Music]
I don't know about you but regardless of
all the Easter eggs and hints which we
all have to speculate on Miley's new
song is a total boss and I can't wait
for Endless Summer Vacation to draw this
coming March